[Música]
este 26 de septiembre se cumplen 8 años
de la desaparición de los 43 normales de
Ayotzinapa en México un crimen de estado
que aún sigue sin resolverse unas 80
personas han sido detenidas por los
hechos hasta el momento
el izquierdista Luis Ignacio violada
Silva regresó este domingo a la campaña
electoral a una semana de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en Brasil da Silva es el favorito según
las encuestas en unos comicios en los
que el actual mandatario Yair bolsonaro
Busca la reelección
una devastación inmensa así define las
autoridades de Canadá el impacto de la
tormenta fión en la costa este del país
que deja al menos un muerto se estima
que se tarde meses en Reparar los daños
de este fenómeno atmosférico sobre
infraestructura clave de la zona
afectada
momento de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de 24 Gracias por continuar con
nosotros Yo soy Juan pupiales estos son
los hechos más destacados del continente
americano el caso de los estudiantes de
la normal de Ayotzinapa cumple 8 años
este 26 de septiembre gracias a la
comisión de la verdad que arrojó los
primeros resultados de la investigación
se determinó que fue un crimen de estado
unas 80 personas han sido detenidas por
los hechos hasta el momento Andrés
granadillo nos amplía ocho años del caso
Ayotzinapa el 26 de septiembre de 2014
43 estudiantes de la normal
desaparecieron la comisión de la verdad
determinó el pasado 17 de agosto que de
hecho se trató de un crimen de estado en
el que participaron militares hasta el
momento se han dictado órdenes de
detención contra más de 80 sospechosos
entre ellos militares policías y
miembros de carteles el viernes 19 de
agosto el ex fiscal general del país
Jesús Murillo fue arrestado tras ser
acusado de desaparición forzada no
denunciar tortura y Mala conducta
oficial para conducir a las pesquisas de
los responsables los familiares siguen
exigiendo justicia por parte del Estado
y claman por encontrar a los
desaparecidos es preocupante decir que
hasta el día de hoy no sabemos nada de
nuestros hijos y eso es que nos duele de
lo más profundo de nuestro corazón no
saber a dónde está nuestros hijos y es
por eso que estamos aquí este dejando
familia nuestros hogares dejando todo
nuestro trabajo por venir aquí por
manifestarnos que queremos la verdad A
dónde está nuestros hijos no podemos
permitir más injusticias basta de
impunidad este viernes en el plantón
organizado en una base militar de México
hubo enfrentamientos con la policía los
manifestantes intentaron derribar las
vallas tratando de Acceder al campo
militar número uno de la capital
que nos Comenten y nos informen porque
no se han ejecutado las órdenes de
aprehensión contra los demás elementos
del ejército desde que asumió el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
ha asegurado que este crimen no quedará
impune
Brasil se prepara para la primera vuelta
de sus elecciones presidenciales del
próximo fin de semana en las que el
actual mandatario evolucionario Busca
seguir en el cargo el favorito de las
encuestas y la izquierda de San Luis
Ignacio de Lula da Silva ha vuelto este
domingo a la campaña Un día después de
haberse ausentado en el segundo debate
presidencial que reunía a sus rivales
más detalles en el siguiente informe
fue un mito infectivo al de este domingo
dato presidencial Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva se dirigió a una multitud de
seguidores en una escuela de samba de
Río de Janeiro apuntó a su principal
rival el actual presidente Yair
bolsonaro y también abordó su decisión
de no participar en el debate
presidencial a principios del fin de
semana
me gusta el debate pero se está
volviendo difícil porque pocas personas
están en condiciones de presentarse a
las elecciones y los otros cinco
candidatos que asistieron al debate solo
tenían un objetivo atacarme porque estoy
en primer lugar
[Música]
un sondeo reciente situado a Lula en
cabeza con el 47% de la intención de
Voto seguido por bolsonaro con el 33 el
ultraderechista le restó importancia a
las cifras
no me fío de las encuestas en 2018
datafolia no acertó nada absolutamente
nada no sé dónde están sus votantes
porque acabo de ir la semana pasada a
granos fui recibido como una estrella
del pop con profundo respeto de la gente
el candidato de Centro izquierda Gómez
dijo que la ausencia de Lula demostraba
que era demasiado confiado
de ser elegido sería su tercer mandato
como presidente procedente de la clase
Obrera se formó como metalúrgico y se
involucró en el activismo sindical fundó
junto a otros el partido de los
trabajadores en 1980 su legado es mixto
se le atribuyen importantes se reformas
como el aumento del salario mínimo pero
su imagen se vio empañada por una
Estancia en prisión condenas por soborno
que luego fueron desestimadas sin
ninguno de los candidatos obtiene la
mayoría de los votos se enfrentarán en
una segunda vuelta el 30 de octubre
las autoridades de al menos cinco
provincias canadienses evaluaron los
daños causados por la obra tormenta
tropical Fiona que toco tierra en el
este del país este sábado a su paso el
fenómeno atmosférico dejó un rastro de
destrucción sin precedentes y se
necesitarán meses para la recuperación
hasta el momento se reporta al menos una
víctima mortal Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
a su paso por la costa del este del país
el ahora tormenta tropical Fiona dejó un
rastro de destrucción en al menos cinco
provincias una de las ciudades más
afectadas fue post o vask donde más de
20 casas quedaron en ruinas entre una
población de 4000 personas
en ese momento les diré que solo estamos
en una pequeña parte de la comunidad
pero el nivel de magnitud de esta
tormenta es muy grande más grande de lo
que pensábamos
en otra ciudad los árboles caídos las
casas destruidas y largas Colas en las
gasolineras imperan en el panorama de
este territorio de Nueva Escocia en esta
región igual que en Isla del príncipe
Eduardo Terranova Quebec y nuevo
brandswake cientos de miles de
residentes permanecieron sin
electricidad las predicciones eran de
una tormenta masiva una tormenta
histórica ciertamente hemos visto eso
Fiona definitivamente dejó una huella en
la provincia el daño es bastante
desgarrador yo no fue la tormenta de más
fuerza en tocar suelo canadiense tras su
paso las labores de recuperación
iniciaron con el envío de las fuerzas
armadas para ayudar en la remoción de
escombros el Primer Ministro Justin
trudó convocó una reunión con el grupo
de respuestas de emergencia para
coordinar el accionar del gobierno en
las labores de reconstrucción
pretende ser el primer intento de la
humanidad de desviar un asteroide la
NASA está lista para comenzar su prueba
de defensa planetaria en caso de que uno
de esos cuerpos rocosos amenazar a la
tierra Por eso se ha proyectado un
cohete en dirección a un asteroide para
desviar su trayectoria y se espera que
el impacto tenga lugar el lunes por la
tarde un informe de nuestros compañeros
de
una nave espacial de varios millones de
dólares tocando contra un asteroide
normalmente sería un accidente caro
frente al cual los científicos
temblarían pero el lunes por la tarde la
prueba de redirección de asteroides
doble de la NASA llamada Darth
colisionará con el asteroide gymorfos
con la esperanza de alterar ligeramente
su trayectoria Es la primera vez que se
intenta una operación de este tipo
por primera vez cambiaremos de forma
medible la órbita de un cuerpo Celeste
en el universo esto tiene un claro
beneficio al asegurar la capacidad
humana para desviar posibles asteroides
amenazantes en el futuro
asteroides amenazantes como los que se
vieron hace 65 millones de años después
de que uno causará la desaparición de
los dinosaurios o más recientemente en
2013 cuando este meteorito dejó 1600
personas heridas en Rusia la misión
Darth se lanzó en noviembre del año
pasado una nave espacial de 30 millones
de dólares no más grande que un
automóvil y más pequeña que la roca de
160 metros de ancho que no supone
ninguna amenaza para la humanidad La
misión de la NASA se ha planificado
cuidadosamente Para que no haga
colisionar el asteroide con la tierra
hay un 0% de posibilidades
independientemente
venga hacia la tierra en realidad es una
situación ideal para que nuestros
equipos sea de científicos e ingenieros
no solo de la misión Dark sino de todo
el mundo aprendan y mejoren con esta
misión
morfos a 22,500 kilómetros por hora el
lunes por la tarde en Estados Unidos el
primer evento transmitido por la NASA en
caso de éxito la misión era de la
agencia espacial europea seguirá sus
pasos lanzando su propia nave espacial
en octubre de 2024
finalizamos con información del mundo
del espectáculo porque la cantante
Rihanna estará al frente del show de
medio tiempo en la próxima edición del
Super Bowl que se va a disputar en
Arizona el próximo 12 de febrero la
artista de Barbados había cancelado su
actuación en 2019 en apoyo al jugador
polémica quien hizo popular la protesta
de la rodilla contra los abusos
policiales ahora desde la organización
definen a Rihanna como un talento
generacional
[Música]
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
en la pantalla de France 24 quédense en
nuestra señal y también la información
continúa en Francia 24.com
[Música]